[Aplausos]
el top 3 de los problemas que mi
audiencia de instagram que es un poquito
más de 200.000 personas es
principalmente tres el primero era
problemas de autoestima la gente no no
no se siente segura de sí misma el
segundo problema es el amor propio la
gente no se ama la gente no se quiere y
el tercer problema es
como me relaciono con los demás hoy
tengo un novio tengo una novia
quién soy yo quién es rojo quién es rosa
chávez para solucionar estos problemas
no entonces luego a práctica un poquito
de mí así rápidamente lo primero es que
soy creador de contenido positivo me
dedico a hacer vídeos que compartan
historias aprendizajes o cuentos que
puedan despertar a los adultos me
encanta esa frase que dice los cuentos
se usan para dormir a los niños pero
para despertar a los adultos entonces es
lo que me dedico desde hace dos años
comparto cosas comparto contenido que
pueda sumarle a las personas la gente
piense que en qué momento decidiste ser
influencers demás pero más que eso va va
mucho más allá yo hace nueve años era
misionero católico bueno soy misional
católico desde hace nueve años entonces
siempre me ha encantado el poder servir
a los demás y me di cuenta que por medio
de los vídeos tú podías hacer el mismo
de llegar a las 100 personas que irte de
misiones una semana una vez al año yo me
iba a un pueblito y les ayudaba a 100
personas no se escuchaba estaba para
ellos y con un vídeo en 5 minutos le
puede llegar esas mismas 100 personas y
seguridad viral que puede llegar a
millones entonces pues como una manera
de optimizar esto pero bueno porque les
platico de mi religión porque por lo
mismo que soy misionero católico
necesitas llevar una dirección
espiritual una dirección espiritual es
cuando un sacerdote de tu confianza ve
hacia dónde quieres que vaya tu vida y
hay un modelo que me encantó que desde
que lo conocí dije yo he aplicado en mi
vida y son tres palabras conócete
acéptate y superarte
en la dirección espiritual trabajamos
mucho en conocer nuestras fortalezas en
aceptar
nuestro todo nuestra identidad con todo
y fortalezas y debilidades y una vez que
ya te aceptas ya puedes superarte ya
sabes dónde estás parado y te puedes ir
a entregar al mundo y si se dan cuenta
está súper relacionado con los tres
problemas que tenemos el primer problema
que es autoestima y eso va con el
conócete el segundo problema es aceptar
el amor propio y el tercer problema es
superarte una vez que ya estás bien
contigo me hice el de ti mismo no
entonces hoy lo que les vengo a platicar
son tres ejercicios que a mí en lo
personal me han ayudado y el primero de
la autoestima quiero que se imaginen
cuando me voy de foráneo soy de torreón
me voy a monterrey a estudiar y cuando
llegó a monterrey llegó becado un break
al ciento por ciento llegó sin lana
todavía para quemarla de chingar el acné
y el acné para la gente que ha tenido es
algo que te pega en la seguridad porque
persona que te está viendo es persona
que tú crees que te está bien lo que
tienes en la cara
entonces para resumir este sentimiento
yo no tenía un acné físico tenía un acné
emocional yo me sentía - me sentía que
estaba porque esto lo que te
vende el mundo el mundo te dice eres lo
que tienes
es como yo le platicaba mi director
espiritual en monterrey y le decía padre
es que aquí la gente súper elitista en
nada más se fijan en lo que tienes y lo
que tienes lo que tienes
el padre mi hijo rolo
la gente te va a ver a ti como tú te ves
a ti mismo
y una disculpa por el pleonasmo por
repetir de ves a ti mismo pero es para
hacer hincapié que como tú te ves como
la gente te va a ver
si tú te sientes menos la gente te va a
ver menos y no porque ni siquiera te
vean menos ellos porque tú crees que
ellos te están viendo como menos
tenemos que enfocarnos en que no somos
lo que tenemos somos lo que damos
cuanta gente hace sonreír cuando te
rodea cuánta gente te recuerda cuando no
estás cuánta gente te marca para pedirte
un consejo tenemos que empezar a ver a
las personas por el tamaño de su corazón
y no por lo que tienen puesto
desde que aprendí eso decidí decirme
igual casi todos los días y por eso no
he visto de pitchers negras blancas
porque creo que la gente se fije en lo
que digo y no se fije en lo que tengo
entonces como el primer ejercicio que
les quiero compartir hoy
es
descubran
y trabajen en sus fortalezas
porque si tú te fijas en todo lo que no
tienes tu autoestima y tu inseguridad
van a ser cosas van a estar en el suelo
pero si tú te fijas en lo que si tienes
en que eres bueno
ahí es cuando tu seguridad y cuando tu
autoestima va a incrementar
dedícate a descubrir y trabajar en tus
fortalezas y hay un ejercicio de
antropología que te dice ve con cinco
amigos y pregúntales en que eres bueno
y les puse ejercicio no les puse consejo
porque es algo que yo hago
constantemente a la gente se nos olvidan
nuestras fortalezas
entonces quiero que este ejercicio vayan
y si tienen bajo autoestima o si tienen
inseguridad quiero que vayan y
practiquen esto
ok una vez que te conoces vamos al tema
del amor propio y esto es un poco más
más complicado porque
me pone una situación muy incómoda
yo era ese güey
yo era el típico chavo que
tenía una novia y al mes cortaba tenía
otra novia en meses cortadas tenías otra
novia ya los dos meses cortadas
poco a poco si me fue
poniendo esta etiqueta de soy culpable
soy culpable de que las mujeres salgan
lastimadas soy culpable de que las hago
llorar soy culpable de que quizás no
estoy hecho para esto para las cosas del
amor incluso llegué a pensar de que una
chance y me gustan los hombres
y creo que es una respuesta es una
pregunta que mucha gente se hace porque
dice creo que porque no encuentra una
pareja
pero leí esta frase que me encantó de un
libro que llama la biografía del
silencio que te dice no puedes condenar
la ignorancia pasada con la sabiduría
del presente
no puedes ir por el mundo diciendo que
eres culpable que eres culpable que eres
culpable
y no puedes ir por el mundo diciendo y
viéndote al espejo y diciendo estás
gorda estás fea
estás pero no valen la pena porque lo
único que está haciendo eso estos
últimos piedras a una maleta una maleta
que la va a ir arrastrando
y vice lastrando tus alas y no dejar que
vueles
cuando trabajo esto en un dirección
espiritual
la frase soy culpable la puede cambiar a
sol
soy lo que soy
la suma de mis experiencias pasadas y
eso me hace en lo que soy hoy soy
alguien más considerado soy alguien más
precavido
pero la culpa lo único que hace es que
nada más te va
molestando y te va deteniendo a lograr
lo que tanto necesitas lograr
una vez que ya te quita está etiqueta
y esta frase me encantó desde un
psicólogo americano en vez de estar con
pegándote diciendo soy culpable soy fea
soy gordo nadie me quiere
te tienes que tratar con la misma
compasión que la que él trataría un
verdadero mes
porque cuando nos corta una novia cuando
nos corta un novio lo primero que
hacemos es decirnos es que estas fea
está feo nadie se interese en ti
y por qué no nos tratamos con la
compasión que deberíamos de tratarnos
tenemos que proteger el amor propio
porque si tú no te quieres a ti quién te
va a creer
entonces el segundo ejercicio si quieren
incremente el amor propio o saben de
alguien que necesite amor propio
cuando te diga algo que estoy fea estoy
gorda estoy de plática bonito contigo
aquí voy con esto este ejercicio es que
la persona cierra los ojos y te imaginas
que te estás viendo cuando era chiquito
cuando la chiquita
qué te dirías
te diría hacer examen ayer es agradable
eres chingón
eres un exitoso
y tu equipo que te irías al tuyo de hoy
te admiro me encanta tu pelo me encanta
tu sonrisa
plática bonito contigo
el tercer paso de las relaciones de
superarte
por lo mismo que
me sentía culpable fui cargando esta
frase que se llama tengo un corazón de
piedra
y creo que muchos nos podemos sentir
identificados tengo corazón de piedra
no puedo amar todo corazón de piedra
lastimó
tan tan fuerte fue esta frase
que termine yendo a terapia ya van
varias veces varios meses que voy con
verón mi psicóloga
y ella me explicó este proceso mental
que tenemos el proceso es tienes una
etiqueta
y en la etiqueta genera un pensamiento
el pensamiento genera una emoción y esa
emoción genera una acción
a que voy con esto la etiqueta de tengo
corazón de piedra
en el pensamiento de no tomar la emoción
viene siendo indiferencia y la acción
cuando se acerca a alguien lo rechaza
porque dices sabes que yo estoy muy
lastimado yo te va a lastimar no puede
amar
después de varios meses en terapia y
vaya que está cabrón y la terapia está
más fácil hacer 'the way' que irle a
platicar tu vida a una psicóloga después
de varios meses ya les puedo decir que
esta frase que tengo un corazón de
piedra
ya se transformó y ya es tengo corazón
hasta el grado que ya rompió récord con
mi novia actual
cuando oí antes yo pensaba en ocho meses
y decía madre eso es una vida
y ahorita ni me cuesta
entonces el ejercicio que quiero que
hagan es que no que trabajes tu salud
emocional y espiritual sino que la
prioriza porque porque le das más
importancia a cuidarte físicamente
cuando por dentro te sientes vacío
porque le da más importancia a verte
bien en el espejo cuando por dentro
estás deshecha
consiguió la psicóloga
consigue a un psicólogo con si un
director espiritual a un monje a tu tío
sabio
consigue alguien pero ve y platica leer
y descifra tu salud emocional y
espiritual
quizá en cuenta los tres ejercicios que
hoy les compartí tienen un factor en
común y ese factor es que en cada uno de
ellos hay comunicación el primer
ejercicio es ve con tus amigos
el segundo ejercicio es ve contigo el
tercer ejercicio es ve con un experto
pero somos seres sociales somos seres
humanos que nacimos para relacionarnos
y te quiero recordar que no estás solo
porque yo estaba ahí ese aumento en
donde crees que
nadie te va a escuchar que no esté
apelar
y así estamos bastante bastantes que no
nos atrevemos a decir lo que sentimos
porque uno como hombre
te dice la cultura los hombres no lloran
si hablas de tus emociones de tus
emociones eres foto
aguanta te como hombre
y hay varios autores que están
analizando esto a tal grado de que desde
1990 hasta el 2015 en méxico se
suicidaron un poco más de 100 mil
personas
el 84%
pero nombres
ocho de cada diez personas que se
suicidan son hombres
y siendo hombre o mujer el mensaje que
quiero dar es que
cuando tú te sientes encerrado y cuando
tú crees que no hay salida
déjame decirte que la vida no se trata
de ti
la vida se trata de los demás
porque nos venden esto es de tu mejor
versión de tu mejor versión sea tu mejor
versión pero para qué sirve ser mejor
para qué sirve tener mejor mente el
mejor cuerpo el mejor espíritu si no lo
compartes con los demás decía san juan
pablo segundo que el sentido más
profundo y más hermoso de la vida es
perdón para donarse a los demás ahí es
donde se siente que ese que tu vida así
está completa
así que
que pueda ser la misma pregunta que yo
me hice
pero en vez de que problemas por
resolver con mi contenido pregúntate
qué problemas por resolver o solucionar
con mi vida
acaso tuviste problemas de autoestima de
inseguridad te voy a van en primaria en
secundaria
acaso no querías tu propio cuerpo te
odias no te gustaba tus curvas no te
gusta tu cara
o acaso te duele bastante él
se cortó un novio una novia no te puedes
relacionar con los demás que eres tímido
enfócate en esos problemas y date cuenta
que uno una persona con esas mismas
circunstancias
ya lo supero
una persona que no es ni siquiera más
inteligente que tú ni más capaz ya pudo
salir de ese bache en el que tú te
encuentras tirado
una persona ya pudo salir de ahí
y que yo conozco todas las historias de
éxito tiene que ver con personas que de
sus heridas
nació su gloria
así que lo último que te quiero dejar en
esta pequeña plática es enfócate en eso
que te quiebra el corazón
esa herida que tienes esa falta
autoestima esa inseguridad ese amor
propio que te falta ese voltear del
espejo y platicarte bonito y decirte
eres un chingón eres una chingón
en eso que igual
crees que nunca se puede relacionar con
la y lo crees que tuviera no tiene
sentido porque estás encerrado en un
vaso de agua cuando la vida no es un
vaso de agua la vida es un mar completo
y un océano en donde tú puedes hacer el
bien
y se va a multiplicar se va a
multiplicar
entonces quiero que se enfoquen en eso
que te quiebra el corazón y que se den
cuenta de que eso es energía potencial
pura para cambiar el mundo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]